estamos en el Ecuador de esta con 27 y
tras seis días de negociaciones llega el
fin de semana hoy sábado las
delegaciones empezarán a crear el boceto
del texto oficial de la conferencia
climática que tendrá que ser discutido
por los ministros y aprobado por todas y
cada una de las partes en los días
finales de la cop la semana comenzó con
una victoria al incluirse en la agenda
oficial las pérdidas y daños una
victoria que será solo simbólica si no
se dan los compromisos sobre un
mecanismo de financiación algo a lo que
china estaría dispuesto a apoyar pero no
se compromete con dinero Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea Aunque reconocen la
vulnerabilidad de los países menos
industrializados evitan hablar de este
polémico tema mientras la ONU los países
en desarrollo y los activistas coinciden
en dejar de lado las palabras y pasar a
la implementación que es como bautizo de
Egipto a esta con 27 los únicos dos
presidentes latinoamérica en hablar
durante esta primera semana fueron el de
Colombia Gustavo Petro y el de Venezuela
Nicolás Maduro que hicieron un llamado a
preservar la amazonía para lo que
esperan el respaldo del presidente
electo de Brasil Lula que estará
presente la semana que viene en la Cope
por su lado Brasil propuso una alianza
con Indonesia y República democrática
del Congo para proteger las selvas
tropicales los tres países que albergan
más del 50% de estos ecosistemas también
se espera el lanzamiento del escudo
global contra los riesgos climáticos una
iniciativa del grupo v20 que incluye a
los más vulnerables a los efectos del
clima y del g7 para financiar la
prevención de desastres sin embargo
según la información que hemos recibido
queda mucho por delante en la
negociación ya que el texto en los temas
cruciales de la cop que son mitigación
adaptación financiación y pérdidas y
daños sigue siendo provisional